va bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono felice oggi siamo
tornati su un gioco che non facevano un
pochettino e che merita di essere
rifatto perché ogni volta che non lo
faccio un po vi è un po una droga sto
gioco questo hunger games ho rifatto un
po i personaggi vediamo sono poi quelli
dell'altra volta un po tutti noi vediamo
cosa cavagliano fuori oggi dal distretto
1 sia i signori cristiano ronaldo e
norman reedus che protagonista ad esso
di destra ending quindi ho dovuto
mettere sente numero due era il jaeger a
elsa che non c'entrano la mazza insieme
però sempre di anime si parlano sto
scherzando ovviamente sto scherzando
sto scheri stretto 3 leonardo di caprio
e carlo cracco mi sento quattro fari
pozza e ariana grande il 75 alberto
angela e demi lovato il sento 6 jason e
giulia benda beh ovviamente signori
distretto 7 favi geniki box come il the
morning gaming problema far squadra
vediamo se riusciamo a vincere almeno
stavolta dice tanto albus silente e
miley cyrus
se però estate fair e distratte riesci
freddie mercury e selena gomez di 6
pollici tokyo e fede è il distretto 12
ho messo same con catherine sotto alto
pita ho sbagliato in realtà però beh chi
se ne frega
che bella questa nuova puntata svelò di
di vincere una possibilità su 24 bounce
mentre i tributi salgono sui loro policy
clacson suona il clacson adesso non il
corno sempre cose nuove anche i magi un
inizio degli hunger games 321 bellissimo
pirata gli hunger games sono milano
nell'ora di punta
stef e demi lovato lottano per una borsa
di gucci tra parentesi steppe si arrende
e si tira il cuor di leone stessa fugge
giulia fugge nella fugge albus silente
spaventa freddie mercury lontano ok
nichi box prende una falce jason sam
tokyo e fa vj condividono tutto ciò che
hanno raccolto prima di correre siamo al
giorno uno ragazzi quindi vediamo come
prosegue nella giornata spero bene
per me sei un rado costringe ferie a
uccidere albus silente o harry potter si
rifiuta di uccidere quindi cristiano
ronaldo la uscite invece quindi è morta
fere prima vittima di oggi sono spaventa
giulia penna e beh perché non l'hai mai
vista senza trucco gesù questo
scherzando giulia è sempre bella tokyo
fa esplodere accidentalmente una mina
terrestre mentre cerca di armarla bene
tokyo vedo che ha imparato dalla casa di
carta some favia aerei haggar cantano
allegramente canzoni va bene nichi box
perdere gli sta dove si trova è quando
mai
jason muore di dissenteria poi vi
chiedete ma come si fa a uccidere jason
e fatelo cagare a spruzzo vedi come
muore questo è il carnet per tutte le
volte che ci ha fatto cagare lui addosso
questo è il karma il calma colpisce
sempre gesù mi dispiace selena e demi
lovato rintracciano e uccidono cristiano
ronaldo questa cosa non ha un senso però
ok no some viene pizzicato dalle spine
mentre raccoglie le bacche spine sono nè
che è successo niente teoricamente
giulia bella giulia pella della tutti
giulia accoltella e regala alla schiena
con un tridente sono scappati ieri
jaeger che sia ronaldo e jason di
dissenteria procedere se le narici e le
forniture mediche da uno sponsor come
ancora disney channel che ti pare al
deretano serena dai basta freddie
mercury nichi boxari era grande e
farisei dormono attorni due di questi
sanno cantare gli altri due
gli altri due sono freddie mercury e
delle grandi terzo giorno ragazzi
teoricamente non servono andò male
quindi vediamo cosa succede
strano freddie mercury colpisce più
volte la testa di carlo cracco contro la
roccia quindi perfetto stef esplode in
modo esplosivo
beh uccidendo albert ha però esplode
uccidendo alberto angela norman reedus
harry potter e nicky box tendere
un'imboscata senza successo a giulia
penna demi lovato e miley cyrus che
invece li uccidono potere alle donne
evento nell'arena o di eventi sono
sempre buoni perché io in genere me la
cavo bene se sopravvive adesso
sopravvive parigi muore lentamente dalle
tossine del tracker
demi lovato sopravvive la ditta per
sopravvivere al presidente bush
all'incoscienza di giulia penna majlis
ali sul punto di morte sam e stef
finisco di posti per correre vengono
punto a morte alle grande punto a morte
sono morti tutti 12 cannoni carlo cracco
alberto angela norman reedus harry
potter nichi box fa vj giulia berna
freddie mercury miley cyrus semstre
fuori alla grande a chi è rimasto vivo
elsa leonardo di caprio demi lovato
albus silente se nella fede è katniss fa
bene proviamo leonardo di caprio e
lancia una freccia nella testa di albus
silente fedez demi lovato ed elsa
combattono demi lovato li uccide
trionfalmente entrambi 2000 volta fatto
fuori il sacco di persone dei note
katniss si rincontrano decidono per una
tregua ragazzoni massivi selena gomez
demi lovato e katniss selena accende un
incendio potevi fare anche un focherello
ma vabbè termini svegli a demi lovato
non può gestire le circostanze e si
suicida quindi gran finale tra serena
che punta e katniss katniss decapita
selena con una spada ha vinto katniss
everdeen giustamente chi tra vincere gli
hunger games è chi la vince katniss alla
fine ha fatto fuori tutti
complimenti che ti senti smentisci mai
hai fatto una sola kill the mila ton ha
fatte 6 e poi si è suicidata
complimenti facciamo alcuna ragazzi
perché quella era era era di
riscaldamento adesso so di essere forte
adesso prima adesso so di essere forte e
felici one il bagno di sangue fresco
mentre tributi salgono sui loro po di
elsa stringe un kit di pronto soccorso e
scappa mai stato si trova una mensa
piena d'acqua una mensa allagata non
allagata la vostra mente la fede ci si
imbatte imbatte nella cornucopia si
nasconde non è massimo nascondersi la
cornucopia sono tanto tanto tanto ad
altra data ad altra data
no che temi si trova a san nascosto
nella cornucopia lo uccide brutta tutta
non ricopro prende una manciata di
coltelli da me ne 1 leo da me n'è uno ad
una ricostruzione arco da meno è una
norma ridoni gli bostridge un kit da
mine 19 stefan rompe il naso di tokyo
per un cestino di pane bravo freddie
mercury lanci un coltello nel petto di
elsa bello
demi lovato e cristiano ronaldo
minacciano un doppio suicidio
fallisce e muoiono beh allora non ha
fallito ha funzionato carlo cracco
lancio la freccia da alberto angela ma
manca e uccide invece fede ok ma voglio
un sacco di morti stavolta il sun è il
salemi cristiano harry potter e fedez
andiamo a è che ho raccomandato ecco lo
fa il giudice l'ha colpita dallo sponsor
finalmente ariana grande convincere
leonardo di caprio a coccole con lei
ebbe chi non vorrebbe essere coccola con
leonardo di caprio catrice tokyo norman
reedus si scontrano katniss di madonna
organic revoca same inarrestabile ne ha
ammazzato arcane ma ammazzato tokyo ha
ammazzato norman reedus ma porca vacca
basta fuori hai già vinto prima basta
che fastidio io non sto facendo una sega
ma continuo a ricevere cibo e acqua de
sponsor sono raccomandato ma jason fa
un'imboscata freddie mercury e lo uccide
a un silente lancia una freccia fere ma
manca invece uccide giulia penna carlo
cracco sanguigna causa di lesioni non
trattate se mette in dubbio la sua
sanità mentale anche io sinceramente
però sono morti ieri jegher tokyo
normali dos freddie mercury sa bene
carlo cracco a metà sono morti io sono
ancora vivo grazie a dio sfruttate tutte
straw una dopo l'altra una dopo l'altra
per quella m'ammazza cane con la ricerca
le barche con me poi mi ammazzo
tradimento io vendo tradito la vita fa
schifo va bene per è svegliato da incubi
abbiamo già detta non la leggiamo i
nuovo basta sconfigge fair in
combattimento ma risparmia la sua vita
ok leonardo calpesta accidentalmente una
mina terrestre
vabbè ciao arti e leonardo vedi leonardo
alla fine sempre così la vita fa schifo
però va bene su salva pure le donzelle
la titanic io tanto schiatto come niente
oste fucile jason finalmente fair e
scatena un esplosivo uccidendo miley
cyrus alberto angela brava ferma
complimenti lo sente fare sono ancora
vivi e attenzione anche di chi sono solo
io di youtube verbale sono morti selena
jason maris a risolver togliere ad un
silente signori aria da grande nichi
steve fere katniss quindi sempre ferie
sono ancora vivi pazzesca sta roba
dovrete lavorare insieme
mick box è svegliata dagli incubi cara
seppe fare parlano degli omaggi ancora
vive di che questi due hanno fatto
proprio la si sono messi d'accordo fin
dall'inizio maledetti o c'è una
strategia sti due mamma mi hanno di
freni ma i bravi valichi fatti valere di
bossi non può gestire circostanze si
suicida bravo che per insegue step che
tris muore o finalmente nel tentativo di
scappare dall arena e non puoi farlo due
volte le già fatto nel film si può fare
maggiore le vacche tossiche aveva tra
lucro io signori gran finale stef e la
sega step ha vinto se forse non ho
capito cosa è successo è capito maria la
grande come morta scusami ariana grande
e non in grado di convincere farà non
ucciderla quindi fede l'ha uccisa e poi
ha mangiato barche tossiche ha vinto
stef browser
complimenti se maledetto potuto vincerò
io questa prova niente ai vendicato me
c'è una rete no perché che tenesse si è
ammazzata da sola però va bene mi fa
piacere fa vj che non hai mai era chille
bravo signori questa era pensiero agli
hunger games di oggi perché non lo
facevo emissione divertente da un po che
non lo fai di farlo suggeriti emili dei
personaggi da far giocare nel prossimo
episodio quando i commenti come sempre
ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale sia già
dalla campanellina alimenta durante i
suoi video che escono lasciato bel mi
piace il commento appunto fatemi sapere
chi volete che inserisca nei prossimi
hunger games e noi ci vediamo come
sempre al prossimo video bello ragazzi
[Musica]